all it's messy splendor this is the
cockpit
where i do my learning
i've got my mac
book
with the extra screen
and over there is my ipad where i study
lessons
and of course i have bought books over
the years don't forget i have to confess
i started korean about six or seven
years ago
studied it for six months and then more
or less
left it and now i am getting back into
my career that i like to buy books
when i study i do and here are only some
of my
korean books i think it's the bulk of
them
and of course i have books
on all kinds of languages
here
german these german
when i studied german quite some while
ago
and of course up here i have my russian
books
quite a stack of russian books
if i'm still that russian
and of course if i go over here
then i got my
whatever we got spanish and french and
over here are my more recent
forays into i guess i got them a bit
mixed here but there's german and
there's czech and so forth all of course
there's lots of other books chinese
japanese
then i have all my audio books here
and over there even more books
so
uh i like to study on link but i also
do like holding books in my hand
cruise ship
now
90 days
90 days
three months
and so i'm going to go to our office now
you may not know this but my main
business actually is the lumber business
and so i'm going to walk into kp wood's
office here but i'm going to head off to
the back
where the here we are and kp was often
and i will how does that work out how do
you turn it around
oh you can't in the back the kind of
guts of the office here here's where
link happens
and uh i'm gonna introduce you to some
of the people now let's see if i can
turn this around properly there we go
alex say hello
very appropriate here as i'm launching
into my attempt to master the korean
language
um
actually and we have galena here galena
who is helping us promote link customer
service
okay and i'll walk now to the back
hopefully i've still got this lined up
with my face i'm learning as i go and in
here i'm going to turn around because
otherwise mark is in the dark he's in
the dark most of the time anyway
and here he is
so what are you what are you pretending
to be working at today i'm just trying
to stay awake usually
i understand same old i understand
though you're taking the 90-day
challenge in what language italian
italian very important to know i forgot
to ask
galena what language are you taking the
90-day challenges in french all right
and you can't say korean i have to okay
well what level you're gonna go from
master to doctorate
anyway
that's the plan all right